hello everybody and welcome to another
part of let's play em needs your custom
story abduction a long time okay I just
I got in a fight with a monster but he
threw sand in my eyes who didn't quite
go well so that was that
he played dirty I really won he just
didn't know yeah all right
I've been in here okay go need to go
this way any totally not scary monsters
hanging around huh
not anymore it's not locked what are you
talking about locked it's not locked
how about this for a key I'll how about
this actual key okay but ah ah ah
closing the door cuz I'm smart
Oh simple lock how about this how about
this needle there we go basement
corridor okay no need for the lantern oh
this looks like a job for the hammering
chipper bunk come on
too sturdy to break Oh what the hell
ah come on this is the only way
durn it darren it up poopy poop
oh man got a hammer and chisel I had a
key why is every time I use a key it
just completely obliterates how does
that even work whatever but I don't
matter okay these are the only two rooms
here
I guess was there another way down here
okay yeah okay um oh now I need some oil
too dark hello
he he has returned somehow back from the
dead with a mite Omega this I must
document the occurrence you're
documenting it right now
last late last night la blah loud
explosion it's a servant to investigate
venture downstairs or ghastly man pale
as a moonlight itself huh the prey is
unable to track me down is he talking
about me or something what's going on is
this some weird reversal role Oh acid
okay GUP right stuff boxes hell boxes
okay hey more down this hallway yep
okay what's in here
Oh do that I do that oh it will not be
long now my love I have found him I can
use him I can return to you I will not
fail again
don't ask me what accents you could just
say it was an awesome accent huh thank
you haha Oh which way that way in there
in there was he in there or over there
what happened where is he coming from I
don't know I don't know
wanna see me was okay yeah he wasn't in
from here
okay okay is rocks ah get away get away
doing I'm in the corner you can't see me
don't even try it
back off oh yeah get out of here don't
lie to you anyway
is it pretty
Oh little sunlight yeah I like me some
sunlight yeah back off
yeah get out of here
I liked you anyway huh oh no no no no
hey hey my room is my room you stay out
I will so bitch-slap you oh don't even
try it don't even try it don't you try
okay are you gonna go away or what come
on now I got stuff to do
I'm a busy man
geez take a head no one wants you around
here hello did you leave are you gone
yeah yeah you better run
oh yeah I'm so great yeah yeah I'm so
great so great oh oh that's the other
into Kevin yeah yep yep oh great
alright gotta get a jar full of acid and
then dump it on the lock because that
makes sense more than using a hammer and
chisel whatever I'm not picky
get out of here door well what is that
some slopping sound not me is it oh
thank you all right no now I can go
straight there and no monsters in my way
Oh basement corridor all right bring it
on what do we got here
Oh lock I'll get a taste of this acid oh
now I can smash it of course that's how
it was exactly an amnesia I think huh
hey hey hey back off I know jujitsu oh
no water monster
water monster I I can see where this is
going Oh nope
Oh social skills oh don't even try it
buddy
oh what's that a fake out oh yeah
oh nothing you got another fine or
epically Oh combo Oh super strong super
handsome ray
what do we know dhanam ah drop me in the
corner nope nope oh yeah yeah oh no epic
jump
oh so skilled oiled thank you
epic ah get out here what's in there
haha get out here dad here ah I'm too
quick I'm too quick Oh some food for you
here we go
munch munch munch enjoy your lunch I'm
out of here
fine oh yeah so cute um I think anything
useful up hello timer timer okay I think
it's coming oh oh
fake out oh I did a monster jump oh yeah
get out of here
ha get out of here nope yep here we go
oh no huh fail monster more oil yay got
oil that was all day was that was Oh
yep yep oh how about a nice big juicy
torso man how'd you like that all
running away up no come back
ah coming back there get out there
oh [ __ ] you [ __ ] you get me out there
what the [ __ ] what couldn't I get up
there what the [ __ ] but [ __ ] as
[ __ ] and [ __ ]
seriously why did that box not want me
to get up there ah [ __ ] you why are you
up [ __ ] this man this games against me
get down here man okay mess with me
useless key Oh get me up there do not
mess with me again
I will I will Jack slap you into the
next dimension oh come on
what the hell no [ __ ] Sherlock
what the hell it was like 10 feet behind
me oh I can't believe the nerve do I
still have my key I better still have my
key yeah thank you yeah you new hose
good for you
all right Oh epic jump ray
ah right behind me uh uh hey get out of
here ah oh yeah Oh Evvie
so epic this is locked so I needed it
probably may not have been who knows who
knows about these things certainly I do
not
all right up this stairs we go huh looks
familiar
yeah I don't like you guys left when the
Eagle sees blue when the Eagles see blue
and the lion sees red one drop of your
blood shall reveal the path ahead okay
Eagle is somewhere Oh II goals and lines
okay
Eagle you don't need to see blue line is
serious of creepy baby
weirdo okay not bad design okay who's in
hair who wants some hall
nobody anything under the stairs nope
never anything under the stairs
alright I gotta cut it here thank you
guys so much for watching and I will see
you next time bye bye